Before we wrap up this lesson, we are going to talk about power. Remember when
we talked about type two errors. This was failing to reject the null when we
should have. We don't want to make type two errors. Which is basically when we
fail to find treatment affects when they actually exist. Since research is so
time consuming and expensive, we need to make it more likely that we find
statistical significance when we should. We do this by increasing power, there
are a lot of things we can do to increase power and I bet you can guess some of
them, if we are testing the effects of different drugs like we did in the last
example. Do we want to test more or less peopel do we want to give each drug to
very similar or very different groups of people. And finally, do we want to
test a small or large dose of the medication. This is assuming that we'll still
be safe in the amount of the drug that we give the subjects.